a peek behind the curtain on Game of
Thrones will reveal a number of things
that may surprise even the show's most
die-hard fans from the special effects
in play to the true life relationships
of the cast and crew these are some of
the most intriguing set images from the
show's production while it should come
as no surprise that the real-life
relationships between professional
actors rarely mirror the characters they
portray it can still throw you for a
loop to discover bitter on-screen rivals
are in fact super great buds such was
the case with Pedro Pascal who played
the fiery doomed Oberyn Martell and Hoth
or us bjornsen who played his sworn
enemy Sir Gregor Clegane they're
shocking duel in season 4 remains one of
the most memorable moments of the series
that's why this picture of the two
actors soaking up raised together seems
so odd
but while the difference between their
on-screen and off-screen relationship
may inspire a double-take or two that
contrast and their real-life physiques
is exactly how they were depicted on the
show with bjornsen towering over his
svelte pal
anyone who has ever spent time on a set
knows the important roles that stand in
sand stunt doubles play these
individuals provide coverage for the
actors between and sometimes even during
filming actress Emilia Clarke stand-in
and stunt double Rosie Mack has received
a good share of media attention over the
course of the show's run thanks in part
to the backstage photos she often posts
on her social media accounts and you've
got to admit all these stand-ins look so
similar to the show's famous leads that
it's actually kind of difficult to tell
them apart at first glance as important
as the actors are and bringing the world
of Game of Thrones to life so too are
the crew members naturally a story this
epic and scope and length requires
hundreds of professionals working
tirelessly at their craft among the most
important of these crew members is
Deborah Riley who serves as the series
lead production designer one of the
reasons the show is caught on with so
many people is because it feels so real
of course it feels surreal because much
of it is many of the grand locales are
shot on location rather than on a stage
or studio backlot
but this illusion is further cemented by
the intricate but subtle set decoration
and design which captures the viewers
attention without being so dazzling as
to distract from the drama of the story
or the performances of the actors you
understand that
you understand the colors you understand
the palette you understand so many
things about the culture that you're
trying to recreate of course not every
locale that appears on Game of Thrones
is the real deal location filming isn't
always an option so in order to achieve
a believable replication the effects
crew will alternate between real and
digital locations this type of visual
trickery is nothing new in and of itself
and Hollywood movies have long used
painted backdrops as stand-ins for
practical scenery but this seamless
blending of outdoor filming with mobile
green screens is just one of the modern
eras most impressive achievements in the
field of CGI given how unforgettable
many of these large-scale scenes have
proven it's fair to say that the show
special effects team has perfected this
kind of digital enhancement sadly not
everything on Game of Thrones can be
done with practical effects in fact one
of the questions fans of the books asked
when the series was first announced was
just how such an epic story could be
realistically adapted to the screen this
was a particular concern since
television wasn't exactly known for
grand spectacle at the time and foremost
among their concerns was the show's
ability to bring Daenerys Targaryen
dragons to life
don't eat the help luckily it turned out
the showrunners knew exactly what they
were doing as a result they've given us
arguably the definitive screen dragons
of the modern era
but for these fantastical creatures
practical effects just weren't practical
and yes this might all look a bit silly
but it really goes to show just what CGI
can really do it's always pretty
remarkable to see the show's actors on
location battling against the elements
such as the case with this image posted
to Instagram by Carice van Houten who
plays the sinister witch Melisandre on
the show she's utterly unflappable she
can stoic ly whether her surroundings no
matter how harsh the conditions thanks
to the power she's achieved through her
practice of the Dark Arts in real life
however then how it is just as
susceptible to the cold is the rest of
us mere mortals it just goes to show
being a successful actor isn't always as
glamorous as it's made out to be one
thing that should come as no surprise to
fans of the show by now is the close
bond shared between various cast members
considering how many characters have
been killed off during the story so far
you've got to imagine this cast member
have probably gotten used to saying
goodbye to one another which is why it's
cool to see they still hang out with
veterans from earlier seasons such as
Jason Momoa who played the late great
Khal Drogo
according to Momoa Instagram account he
met up with his Game of Thrones buds in
Belfast during filming for the final
season of course these pictures sparked
plenty of speculation that the once and
future Aquaman would be returning to the
series in some capacity during its final
season whether that turns out to be the
case or not it's still always nice to
see old friends keeping in touch check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Game
of Thrones are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the belt so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]